do you have high hopes for the
Assassin's Creed movie Oscar nominee and
lead actor Michael Fassbender certainly
does in his interview with Empire he
said he thinks it can overcome
expectations he even compared it to the
matrix considering the Assassin's Creed
series is about a simulated world inside
of the animus the matrix comparison
doesn't seem too far off Fassbender said
I've always thought about the matrix
when we've approached this this idea of
DNA memory elevates it from a basic
fantasy genre piece because you have
something an audience can actually
believe in then the journey becomes so
much more elevated because you're on
board in a different way Fassbender also
commented on the movies use of practical
effects the 120 foot leap of faith
you'll see on screen was really
performed by stuntmen damien walters no
cgi there we're certainly looking
forward to seeing the finished product
and for all the latest on Assassin's
Creed movies and games you're already in
the right place
you